why
so Civil War issue number three picks up
after the events of both Italians and
Civil War issue number two and what we
see is the story really kind of begins
to progress is Reed Richards of the
Fantastic Four attempting to enlist the
aid of Black Panther for the fifty state
initiative on behalf of the President of
the United States
now the fifty state initiative is really
kind of the next step after superheroes
are required to register we really kind
of see that what the fifty state
initiative requires is that superheroes
really kind of begin to become a police
force and so they really kind of take
over for the police when the police just
aren't able to do apprehend criminals or
really aren't able to deal with the
situation as well as superheroes it's
really just kind of a militarization of
superheroes in the United States
Black Panther declines furthermore
what's really interesting about Reed
Richards is that Black Panther really
kind of asked them how it is that Johnny
Storm is doing and we learned that Reed
Richards actually hasn't seen Johnny
Storm for a few days he's really kind of
inside track with something else that we
will see later on in the Civil War
storyline and Black Panther gives him a
piece of advice and his advice is to go
see Susan storm because Susan storm has
really kind of spent all of her time
with Johnny Storm here and in truth if
Reed Richards doesn't really kind of
begin to get back with his family again
he could possibly lose it from there we
switched to ant-man and wasp or Yellow
Jacket I think at this point in wasp
trying to enlist the aid of dr. strange
however they meet Wong who of course is
the assistant of dr. strange and Wong
informs then the dr. strange is in
seclusion until the events past he's
really kind of fasting for 40 days and
40 nights hoping that it'll somehow
bring it into this conflict from there
we switch to Tony Stark trying to
recruit the x-men now this is really
what's kind of interesting here because
of course at this point in time Emma
Frost and Cyclops are both the leaders
of the x-men and Emma Frost actually
declines the offer to join Tony Stark's
I guess team of superheroes and the
whole reason is because there's really
kind of a lot of animosity between the
x-men and the Avengers at this point in
time after the events of Cassandra Nova
which we haven't gone over yet and her
attack on Jay
notion and the destruction of Genosha
there were really no Avengers stepping
in to help the x-men there was really no
one coming in here to assist the x-men
and their attempt to keep Genosha alive
and so Emma Frost states that she will
stay that the x-men will stay neutral
and they will not join Captain America's
side if the government leaves them alone
because at this point the government
have kind of considered the x-men to be
this sort of sovereign nation unto
themselves just because there's so few
mutants left after the events of M day
and so we really kind of see Tony Stark
leaving empty-handed but as he's meeting
with happy hogan to leave the x-men
premises we see Bishop step out and ask
Tony Stark forward in addition we switch
to Captain America daredevil hercules
and goliath and they're really kind of
meeting with the new identities that
Nick Fury has given them the identities
aren't necessarily everything they'd
hoped for but at the very least it'll
give them a chance to continue their
actions of being superheroes while also
being able to revert back to identities
that no one's really aware of they
receive a report of a fire at a
petrochemical plant on the Hudson River
and they leave to assist now at the same
time what we also see is that Johnny
Storm has come to and wants to know
where his sister is at this point we
switch to the petrochemical plant and we
see the cable among others have really
kind of joined Captain America as they
assist to help those individuals who
have been trapped in this fire but cable
realizes there's no real communications
there's no one really asking for a
there's no one calling for help over any
of the phone lines or any of the I guess
maybe radio channels or anything and so
it's just it's eerily quiet at this
point cable realizes that the
petrochemical plant is owned by Tony
Stark and realizes that the entire thing
is a trap from here captain
I'm sorry Iron Man and his team arrive
to inform Captain America that it is a
trap and it was the only way to get them
all in one place from this point going
forward to really kind of begin this
huge conflict that goes on between all
the superheroes a shield is really kind
of informed by Maria Hill to stay
hands-off they're really kind of there
in a support capacity and they really
don't need to intervene at this point in
time and the fight is really kind of
going both ways I mean it's really kind
of kind of an even even event for the
most part of course we see that Captain
America booby-traps Iron Man's
armorer we see that all these different
individuals are engaging in conflict
everybody's fighting and there's really
no guarantee as to which side it will go
to until Hercules steps in and Hercules
is a very very strong one of the
strongest Marvel superheroes he has the
ability to rival Thorin strengths at
which point once he gets into the
conflict we see that Maria Hill says
that codename lightning has Authority
and then we see that Thor arrives with
that being said I'm going to go ahead
and bring this video to an end I know it
wasn't necessarily as expansive as some
of the other civil war stories have been
but what we'll see going forward is that
things are really going to kind of pick
up and speed and things are going to go
much much faster and there's going to be
a lot more going on so thanks for
watching guys and I'll catch you all
later peace
you